you wouldn't believe actually how how
satisfying it is to have people come to
security talks when I did my first
security talk 15 years ago there were
literally two people in the room and one
left early so thanks for coming welcome
hi that's not the spirit hi thank you
exactly one year ago it was broken me I
think even in the same room giving the
same talk or at least the same title
has anyone been to this talk one year
ago a couple of people so we were toying
around with some ideas and we should be
showed some early prototypes and people
said like where we asked the code we
asked the code can you can we have the
code and we didn't real we didn't really
feel comfortable by the time to handing
out the code so we said no there's no
code so kind of this talk is the story
kind of what happened after okay so for
the last 12 months so to speak and the
whole problem space is this broken I
have been working for many many years on
this thing called identity server which
is an open-source implementation for
MIDI connect and off and it basically
solves the authentication problem so
whenever you need to authenticate users
and you have a you know a reasonably
complex system then identity server is
kind of like a Swiss Army knife for
implementing authentication and single
sign-on and all these things and even if
you know even if that sounds
intimidating authentication is easy yeah
because because once you know all the
facts and all the requirements it's
pretty much like there's only one right
solution to solve the problem whereas
authorization there are so many opinions
and styles and different approaches that
might bring you to the same solution
yeah
so basically ultimately after the
customers were done with authentication
it's like okay so now where is your open
source library for just doing you know
apt or user authorization and I'm done
and
that didn't exist okay so and the main
reason why this probably will never
exist in in one line of code thing right
is because it's it's very very
application specific various
authentication is something more
universal
so our tip you know our kind of answer
was always yeah that's application
specific you have to write something
that is exactly working with your
application and we never really had the
time to say like okay so is there
something is there a common ground that
would be worthwhile abstracting into a
more general-purpose library or even
pattern or approach and that's what we
basically were thinking about to start
with on a background thread kind of and
then for the last 12 months more more
more full-time and that's what this
thing is called called policy server so
what what this talk is not did this talk
is not really about policy server I I
don't want to sell you anything it's
more like why we made the decisions that
we made while implementing a reusable
authorization library yeah and maybe
that's some inspiration for you guys as
well so the slide deck you can find on
speaker tech comm slash least privilege
and it has all the links in there so
that's what you should download if you
want to know more details so yeah so a
policy server we started building this
open source library and then it became
more complicated and more complicated
and more complicated and we made a split
basically between there's an open source
version of policy server which you can
get from from github and we also have a
commercial version now which has you
know the enterprise-e stuff so the way
we approach the problem is since we have
the luxury of talking to many different
companies right so we started asking
them all you're like
how do you do authorization how would
you do authorization if you had the
chance to do it again how are you
planning to do it for the next
application you're you're writing and
the funny thing is when you ask 10
people you get like 15 different
opinions because no one was really ever
happy with what he did kind of like yeah
we did like that it worked out well in
the beginning and then we started
hacking around this and hacking around
that and eda we had not enough or we
were too ambitious
regardless typically our observation was
that people read
reinvent the wheel from many times for
the next application in the next
application and you know like and not a
lot of people went for the last mile so
to speak once the library was done kind
of it was working they never took that
took the time to build the UI over that
or maybe an API or maybe something to
manage their authorization rules and you
know many many times they are you I was
sequel server management studio so so we
asked them and there are there are many
approaches right but the free the free
most common things we saw and that are
working is basically role based
authorization right I mean that's a
no-brainer if you are in the marketing
role you can launch the marketing
application which is pretty
coarse-grained the next typical
abstraction we are seeing is permissions
right so you may be you know can do this
or can do that or you know it's allowed
to do this sometimes permissions exist
independently of roles sometimes using
roles to group permissions together like
if you are in that role that gives you
automatically these dismiss permissions
for example and then in your code you
can you know do more fine-grained checks
for example the other style is more like
a resource-based style right where you
have resources in your system like a
document or a contract or a customer and
you attach like you know like access
control entries to it yeah pretty much
like a NTFS does that in in Windows you
are like where you have an
echo that hangs off a file or a
directory and there are some challenges
with that for example inheritance
they're like what if the folder has
these actors were what you know should
that or you know go down to all the
containing objects and so on what you do
with orphaned echoes right so what if
the guy leaves the company but he still
isn't the actual it will be an orphaned
entry and you often see that in Windows
as well right when you're opening like
in NTFS like look at the echo dialog and
there are numbers there but not a name
that means that guy has left the company
in between and all we have is TTS ID in
there but the account is gone for
example um and permutations of that
style
kuvira's verses commands it's another
interesting challenge right most
authorization frameworks we've seen they
deal only with commands
yeah like am i allowed to do this yes
then do that but what if you like you
know like um give me all the contracts
that I'm allowed to see ma'am it's very
very specific to the data store you are
using yeah some people in checked where
clauses in sequel statements you know
things like that I've even seen a
product which I think was an interesting
idea but I think it's crazy it's a it
was a TDS reverse proxy so basically
something that sits between your
application and sequel server and you do
your queries and this guy basically adds
the way of statements dynamically so
these are the things I've seen pretty
commonly and I think that's what you can
say is how typically you approach
authorization - the very very specific
things that are really really specific
to your company what I've also seen is
that it's very very easy to blur the
lines between authorization and business
rules like where does authorization end
where do business rules start where
where does some you know like core
business logic kick in
and putting business logic into
authorization rules I think is it's not
going to work and the best example I
have for that is this thing called XML
the even the name is hard extensible
applic access control markup language
has it has anyone ever used that exact
mo I don't see anyone one guys waving
okay so XML try basically to externalize
all kinds of business rules and
authorization rules to an external
system
so whenever basically you wanted to
check a rule or something you had to
export context from your system to the
external system now the expensive had to
pass the context and then they had to
write rules and return you an answer and
that feels overly complicated yeah you
are basically it feels like you're
spending more time making accessible
happy then yourself yeah so that is that
is the first example from the exact
remote documentation that's the simplest
rule you can write okay and it only
specifies if you can log into an
application between 9 a.m. and 5 p.m.
okay so one person reasons that the yeah
but in our support Jason as well yeah I
don't think that makes it any better
okay so I don't think and given that
only one guy was waving it wasn't a huge
success
in the long run many people try to use
it in the first place I don't think I
think we need mean bean even better
separation of concerns so our
observation basically ended up saying we
have three different types of
authorization one is more like you know
like am I allowed to use an application
or am I allowed to use an API for
example yeah that often can be handled
at a at a global policy style level
where you in your application of a
global a global authorization rule that
you know make sure that only the users
are coming in is allowed to do it is
allowed to come in actually
at the API level you can often manage
that with the tokens I mean if you know
if you don't have a token for an API you
can't call it right that's one thing
once you are in the application and
you're trying to access a specific
feature then I think the role permission
resource style works pretty well but
once you are inside the feature right
and now it really is all dependent on
the parameters you pass in or the
payload or you know like properties of
the things you want to modify I think
that is business logic and not
authorization logic anymore and I think
there's nothing wrong with writing apps
specific Authenticator ization
frameworks but I don't think you can
generalize that because it's so
application specific so that's one thing
do you remember this guy windows se men
not s men windows se man shipped with
Windows Server 2003 and it took four
years for someone that might have to
write an article about it as you can see
and it was the best kept secret yeah and
the idea we i liked windows SE meant a
lot if you go back on my block to 2004
or something I wrote crazy
integration stuff for asp.net webforms
at a time so what I liked about se man
is is that basically it gave you an
additional layer over your identity
system so the identity system is Active
Directory because you know it was 80
times and Active Directory I hope I
don't tell you anything new was never
designed to be an application
authorization mechanism right when they
designed Active Directory they had users
and groups and you can basically control
access to printers and file shares and
these kind of things but it was never
designed to be you know like that at
eight
groups become authorization mechanisms
for applications okay that's why they
created a seaman ma'am an SE man
basically sources they use us from
Active Directory so basically you can
create groups or well first of all you
didn't create applications okay so an
applications can have application groups
and they can roles as they call it then
you can have roles can be assigned to
tasks and tasks can even you know go
down to operations and then you can add
a ad users to those roles okay so it was
a separation of concern between the
identity system and the authorization
policy which i think is the right way to
do it yeah and the other reason why many
people liked it was because it had a UI
now it was built in into Windows and
actually I was surprised it still exists
it seems like they removed the ability
to create authorization stores because
it's deprecated but you can still open
them so if you have old ones lying
around but yeah you know nothing ever
goes away in Windows so I guess a seaman
is one of those things as well so when
we thought about how policy server
should work we my idea was I want
something like this but you know like
teleported to modern application design
yeah so where it's not dependent on
Active Directory where you you know have
modern protocols like openly connect you
know of where you have a claims-based
identity and where you can basically use
an arbitrary identity system not not
idea or whatever just whatever you want
and have something that sits on top of
that and doesn't you know many vendors
try to sell you like identity and access
control software where you lock into the
whole stack your users must be managed
by them your pull the permissions must
be managed by them it's all being buried
in one system I don't like this
what I want is that you can choose an
arbitrary identity system and can layer
your authorization on top of that so now
given that this architecture is really
common these days your people have
identity providers there is some
discussion going on now what do next may
also how do we distribute how do we make
authorization rules like roles
application roles and permissions and
these things available to applications
and one one opinion is a very common one
it should go into the security token
right so we already have this thing that
issues tokens to our application so why
not just piggyback on that mechanism and
stuff in our authorization policies in
there as well a couple of products out
there do that and and that that's their
their style of doing it I don't to be
honest I I don't like this approach
because I've seen it go wrong so many
times so let's have a look at this token
here yeah so the token a security token
typically contains information about the
authentication yeah like who issued the
token how was the user authenticated
when was he authenticated and where can
you use that token that data that I
would say is authentication metadata
it contains identity yeah for example
what's the user ID of the user and maybe
you have some other data you want to
ship around like a display name for
example and then this and that's
something I don't like
okay so tokens should represent the
caller and the user and where they can
be used and identity information that
describes those three parts okay that
that's my mindset at least now
permissions clearly don't fall into this
bucket okay
delete
data okay manage customers right change
treatment plan they are all pretty
pretty generic things and one one fact
is that in ooo for example you see that
the audience here a token can be used at
more than one API yeah so you have maybe
you know like a pet pack in W s star you
were used to getting one token for API
one getting a token for API to getting a
token for API free the style he stays is
more like you get one token and it
inside the token you define where it can
be used so you have one token for
multiple api's huh
but what if now this guy has the delete
data permission in API one but not an
API - for example yeah so maybe when you
start assigning that this makes total
sense to you and then you start adding
api's to it and then these permissions
become ambiguous yeah and you start
shipping them around and one thing I
learned from experience is adding claims
to a token is super easy right you just
write a one line of code or a new claim
job done but removing a claim from a
token because you realize it was the
wrong claim or the semantics are wrong
is super hard because you don't well
often you don't know who started taking
dependencies on the existence of the
claim or even the semantics yeah so I
don't like this
the other problem is with tokens is that
typically tokens get created at
authentication time ok so when I log on
to a system I'm doing my orphans getting
my tokens what happens if two hours
later for example or even shortly later
my permissions change right the only way
to update this is getting new tokens
yeah for example in Windows Windows has
the exact same problem yeah so when you
log on to your Windows machine in the
morning and then an admin adds you to a
group the only way to make this group
membership effective for you is to log
off and log on again because they
collect your group memberships at login
time
okay so if you have things that often
change tokens are definitely not the
right vehicle to ship them yeah
and the last one is this this section
your rolls rolls is a an often discussed
thing yeah so should you put roles in
the token or not so in my mind there are
two types of roles one I call identity
rolls yeah so basically in this case to
talk to roll for example yeah so when
you when you log on to the system you
are a doctor well you are a doctor it's
part of your identity okay but approver
what does it prove I mean yeah I mean
what does he approve and depending on to
which API I'm connecting I might be able
to approve different things so that the
approval roll my in my mind falls more
into the authorization pocket and into
the identity pocket yeah this is kind of
like a hospital scenario because one of
my customers that inspired the whole
thing did Hospital software and when a
user locked in to the system they always
got one role doctor nurse or patient
yeah and there was never a situation
where the doctor was a nurse or the
nurse was a doctor so for them it made
total sense and that I think is part of
the identity of the user ma'am same as
like with your your your passport right
so on your on your ID card you have a
date of birth claim on a drive it
doesn't have a claim on it says allow to
drink alcohol because the rules change
depending on which end point you're
talking to right so in Germany it's 16
depending on what you're drinking in in
the state is 21 someone recently said in
in Ireland it's 8 so so the DLT allowed
to drink permission is something that is
handled at the bar right or the API
endpoint if you like where is the date
of birth is something universal and
that's where I in my mind make it make
the distinction right
identity is something Universal
authorization is something
application-specific
okay that's at least my mindset I know
that there are many products out there
which which do it exactly like this you
know that's just my opinion
oh yeah and to be honest I've seen many
companies that started out with that and
then it got completely out of hand right
because you started to putting
permissions in the token now we add more
API is more API is more API is more
applications the tokens get bigger
bigger and bigger and that wasn't the
intention of an access token right an
exit or should be a compact data
structure that you ship around so that
you can get access to to api's so yeah
so what what if I would use this token
that I just showed you in my Hospital
scenario with the patient a PID oncology
API and the cardiac API I'm really
hoping that the same doctor who has the
change treatment plan permission in
oncology doesn't have the same
permission in cardiac because he's
probably not not qualified for that okay
so yeah so that is you know what I in my
mind is identity is not permissions and
I think you shouldn't mix them together
it might look sensible to start with it
will get out of hand once your system is
growing what I think is the case is that
identity plus a permission system that
becomes the actual authorization data
and so that's let us to basically
basically designing the architecture in
a way that you have you should have two
distinct providers the identity provider
and the authorization policy provider
and I'm not saying this must be a server
or an API whatever just think of that as
logical functions in your in your
architecture so the way I think we think
it works really well is you know the
first step is the user logs on to the
application you authenticate with the
identity provider he gets his tokens the
identity token for the client the
the access tokens for the api's then
then obviously the client the UI has
certain authorization requirements like
you know showing this button or you know
removing this menu item whatever so the
UI would connect to the policy provider
send in the user's identity get back the
UI specific permissions and when the UI
talks to the api's each api will have
based on the identity of the user
probably different authorization
requirements so they also connect to the
policy provider and they and they're
where you get your authorization data
from ok and then if you put a nice UI on
top of that you make many many people
happy right because suddenly a
non-technical person or a non developer
can change those rules without you
having to recompile your code now or
think of software that you're shipping
to customers right that the end customer
should have a nice way to you know to
configure who is allowed to change the
treatment plan and who's not
ok so so basically how policy server
works is and that that regardless of the
open-source order or the commercial
bonus that we have a runtime a client
library so to speak yeah and the idea is
that the client library takes the
identity of the user which is the thing
that falls out of the authentication
process and sends it to a rule store or
a policy store whatever you might want
to call it the important part here is
the application context right so
different applications might have the
same user but depending on the context
of the application you might get back
different permissions mam and you know
and we didn't try to do any rocket
science here yeah like it's a simple API
call you send a list of claims to the
server you get back roles and
permissions chopped down ok so that was
the first part about how how we designed
that now the second part which is
completely
independent of if you're using poll
server or whatever or building your own
whatever is some strategies how to
integrate that into client applications
so obviously the the at the very most
basic level you won't have some sort of
client library right so something that
the client application or the api's can
call obviously you can be as smart as
you want in that client library maybe
you don't want it to a network
round-trip every time maybe you have
some caching maybe there are freshness
requirements depending on the
application right so one application
might say my staff changes infrequently
so give me a fresh policy every hour
whereas maybe you know like in the
emergency room the the permission to cut
open a patient is something you should
check right now and don't wait for an
hour for - here so that's one thing let
me show you that first so what we have
here is a really really simple and and
that that's all on github I have a
really simple application where you can
log in that simulates your identity
system ok it could be anything it could
be Active Directory it could be identity
server it could be whatever you name it
ok but the outcome of authentication
will always be claims ma'am so we have
two users here Alice and Bob obviously
and all the other users are patients as
you can see because they are very sick
okay so when we log in here
let's Ellis then all these pages is
showing basically is the identity of the
user right so in a CHP core you have
these so-called schemes that's the
password scheme because I came in wire a
password and I have two claims one is
the subject ID of Ellis which is number
one and her display name okay so in this
case I'm having my authorization
policies in a JSON file could be
anything right it could be an API it
could be a database whatever but
basically that's where we map the
identity to application data yeah so in
this case you see we have two roles here
or free doctor and nurse and patient
ma'am there are there are a couple of
ways how you can map use us to
application roles one is static mappings
obviously right if you have all the user
names or the subject that is you can
just put them into application roles and
another thing is it's dynamic mapping so
when the identity system emits a certain
claim for example we can automatically
map him to the to the doctor application
role yeah or you could come up with
arbitrary expressions that's what we do
in our commercial product where you can
just write c-sharp code yeah and it then
basically based on the incoming claims
you map them to two arbitrary
application roles you see here the
patients the patients don't have any
status static mapping at all so anybody
who has an identity role of customer is
a patient from our point of view okay
and then here in this section you have
two permissions so we have a C patient
and a perform 30 permission and we can
basically specify who is allowed to do
that perform surgery is done by the
doctor request pain medication should
only be done by patients okay so and
then in my in my few here oh that's what
I wanted we have basically a service
living in the DI container the policies
of our client we are read
the policy from the Chasen file in this
case and that makes available a policy
server runtime client object that you
can now inject into the constructor and
then you can just call that by saying
evaluate async and you pass in the
claims that you want to run the
evaluation on and that might be your
current user which is in this case it's
the current user right but we you can
pass in an arbitrary claims principle so
if you want to construct an identity on
the fly and say okay what would this
user or this identity be allowed to do
you could do that or if you want to
figure out what other users are allowed
to do you know same idea so when we run
it again
okay so now we are seeing the results of
that policy so it's a elías it's a
doctor so he has two doctor role and we
have to free the free permissions that
she has and if I would remove Alice you
know just say it's not one and two it's
free and two then obviously Elias
wouldn't have those permissions that
make sense okay so you know if you're
writing a brand new application this
might be all you need right you're
having this client library you're
calling into it and based on that you're
building your your logic another
approach you can take
and I'm not to be honest I'm I'm not a
fan at all of the authorized attribute
with the roles equals something because
I think this leads to really hard to
maintain code because you know that
might work well if some person on stage
demos that with with one controller like
like like I'm doing right now yeah but
once you have more controllers you're
many controllers and you have these
roles sprinkled everywhere it's really
hard to remain maintain that code but I
and that's the other thing I learned
while talking to customers many
different people have different styles
okay and I guess I have to accept that
not always my style is the best I guess
anyways so let's say you have an
existing investment into into the
authorized attribute okay or you just
like that or maybe you want to use you
know the built-in dotnet API is that
work with claims like you know fine
first and find all and has claim and all
these things another possible way to
approach that would be to automatically
call the policy system so one other
thing we have here is a middleware yeah
and all this middleware really does is
it runs after the user has been
authenticated and it takes the current
user calls the policy system gets back
gets back to permission
rolls and turns them into planes okay so
when I run that again now with the Edit
with the Edit middleware I should see an
another authentication scheme in my
application one is the identity the
password that's how we authenticate it
and the other one is called you know
policy or middleware whatever so in
other words that's a low-level feature
of claims principle if you if you have
ever seen that claims principle can act
as a container for multiple claims
identities so you don't need to have
only one identity in your principle you
can have more than one so and in this
case this one here represents the
authentication data in this case here it
represents the permissions and the roads
okay and now since they are now claims
in the principle you can use you know
your your beloved authorize attribute
with the roles equal something or you
can just say you know use our thought
has claimed this or user dot you know
whatever now so that's the nurses only
action whatever nurses only means so if
I would execute that I'm a doctor I
shouldn't get access okay but if I'm a
nurse no no I'm a nurse I should be able
to do whatever nurses do okay so that's
another approach ma'am
or you come up you know if you have the
luxury of using HP nerdcore they have a
new built-in authorization api which is
actually far superior than what we had
before
it's called policy based authorization
and now the word policy gets completely
overloaded but the point is you know my
main points of criticism the 50:50
authorized attribute were that you are
coupling together authorization logic
and controller logic in in one place
that that developer at development time
already needs to know who will be
allowed to call this code which might
not be the case
so separation of concerns and
testability right I mean have you ever
tried to write an automatic test that
makes sure you have the right authorized
attributes in the right place it's it's
messy okay so we were talking to
Microsoft for many many years and said
like listen we need something better
than this yeah but they didn't have the
luxury of doing breaking changes so much
until a spinet core came by where they
exercise that luxury quite a bit and we
gave them a prototype and okay here's
our prototype can you make it pretty and
the main blocker back then to make it
pretty was that the lack of dependency
injection in in in in asp.net so when
they released a speed core they also had
a new security guy on the team which
happens to be a friend of mine maybe Ted
has helped and he basically took that
and and put it into the product and it's
called policy based authorization and
the idea is it tries to solve all the
the pain points mainly the decoupling of
authorization logic from your actual
code and the testability ma'am oh and by
the way that the most common question I
get when I show that it's like does that
also work with nbc5 and with the API and
he answers yes there's a guy David parks
eight who begged ported the whole thing
to to katana
so you're now you can use that now in in
pre-aids peanut core code so how does it
work
the idea of the policy system is that
you can as I said separate the policy
logic from the actual controller logic
so the idea is you're putting the
so-called authorization policies into
the DI container you give them a name
and policies are basically a list of
named requirements ma'am
so you can basically say okay to be able
to prescribe medication the user must be
authenticated you must have a permission
of prescribe medication but you can make
these policies arbitrarily complex may
also you can you know could call the
database or whatever you want to do okay
so let's just copy this guy over to my
code here okay so now I have a policy
called prescribe medication I think in
my code I call it differently let's have
a look oh it's called performed surgery
okay whatever prescribe medication
prescribed medication okay so what
happens now is this when I hit the the
prescribed medication function it
basically looks in after the I container
finds that policy execute it right and
if the policy is succeeds you are
allowed access the nice thing about that
is now that that when your requirements
change you only have to change them in
one place and all the controllers where
you think the policy gets gets the
update for free so to speak so we've
said in place so have a look you must
have the permission of prescribe
medication to call this thing let's have
a look if I log in as a as a doctor I
should have this permission and that's
working okay whereas if I'm a patient
then who is a patient you know he
shouldn't be allowed to do that that
makes sense
okay so that's a nice system and as I
said it's a
it's extensible I'm gonna show you an
example of that in a second
oh yeah the other nice thing I like I
like about a new policy API is that you
can use it programmatically so I
personally am NOT a huge fan of
attributes I never understood why dotnet
developers so much laughs their
attributes
I mean it's code a path the method name
as opposed to code below the method name
it's but it's code right so the nice
thing about the new policy API in a
spirit koi is that it's just a service
in the DI container you can get a
dependency on your I authorization
service here and then you can call these
policies imperatively now and again
what's nice is you can pass in the user
you want to test against okay so it can
be the current user it can be a
different user and you're getting back a
true or false basically and can act on
that okay and that is basically a you
know DTD or the authorized attribute has
a pretty static behavior right yes or no
more or less yeah but what if let's say
you wanna if he's not allowed to
prescribe the medication maybe the user
should be able to see the list of
medication that has been prescribed but
not be able to add something to it right
then the authorized attribute wouldn't
work here so here with code you have all
the flexibility you need the other nice
thing about that is that now you can
test your policies automatically right
so you can now write automated tests you
create users with certain claims your
shapes and forms you feed them into the
policy and you can make sure that you
get back expected results yeah and when
some other person six months down the
line has the task to extend the system
and it changes the policies your tests
will show him immediately if he broke
the policies or or not right so that's I
think very nice the other thing you can
do which I think you shouldn't do but
I'm showing you nevertheless is you can
now do dependency injection in fuse so
you can get get your I offer ization
service infuse and conditionally render
UI is based on the permissions of the
user ma'am I don't like this approach
too much because it you know
more code on views which i think is a
not necessarily the best idea but I've
seen that being used quite for a good
cause in my in layout pages right but
you have like your master a navigation
system and maybe based on on the user
properties you are showing different
things ma'am the only thing that's weird
now yeah with this approach is when we
look back on our on our policy
definition here is now now that you have
to create a policy for each permission
you have in the system which I don't
think is the right thing if you want to
create a policy which is more complex
and as a part of that checks a
permission that's fine but if you have
like a one-to-one mapping from policy
names to permission names that doesn't
sound like the right thing to do or at
least it's it's a bit tedious right so
there's a nice feature in ASP nerdcore
which is called an authorization policy
provider just to make it even more
complicating yeah and the idea is that
you did there's an API that you can
implement that creates authorization
policies on the fly for you so you don't
have to statically define them but
basically you get to see the name the
string and then you can create them or
fabricate them on the fly so what we did
with with that feature is when I add
that here it wires up a so called policy
provider and now whenever the policy
system sees something like this it first
checks
is there a statically defined policy in
my application and if not I'm just going
to create one that just checks for the
permission with the same name okay
that's quite nice so even if this policy
is now not statically defined it should
still work and you can see that it works
because I don't get an exception because
otherwise I would get an exception here
okay so it it still works as as expected
so that's quite nice as well and the
last thing I think I want to talk about
is a cost
requirements so the one thing I don't
like about the policy system is not the
pole system itself but the way it's
mostly presented and it gives you the
impression that to check something with
this API you need claims for that right
so you want to check that whatever
create a claim for it put it on the
claim principle that's how it works
that's not how it works yeah it's just
what Microsoft gives you out-of-the-box
yeah this require claim method is
actually an extension method and you can
write your own extension methods which
wire up your own custom requirements so
that would be a custom requirement yeah
so let's say yeah in addition to the
prescribed medication thing you you you
need more input data yeah like what kind
of medication do you want to prescribe
and how much of it okay
and to do that you just derived from I
offer a sation requirement which is just
a marker interface it's it's for di
purposes and you model your domain data
and then basically the trick here is is
that you're writing a class that checks
the requirement at runtime so you see
basically here it's an authorization
Handler of tea and the tea is your
custom requirement and what we are doing
now we are inside the custom requirement
handler we are using our client library
to now check permissions right which
makes total sense because you're having
this client library and you can use it
wherever it makes sense so you can see
that the logic is a bit contrived here
but you know if you have the permission
of prescribing medication that's good if
there if the amount is less than 10 you
are allowed otherwise you need to be a
doctor and if it's a placebo well the
nurse can do it as well regardless of
the amount right and when when you have
this guy you put it into the DI
container here yeah that's a medication
requirement handler and then whenever
you are invoking a policy that has this
requirement your handler will be called
and you are allowed to run whatever code
you need to run to come to an
authorization decision so let's see
here's the prescribed medication action
right it has a name in the mound
you are newing up this medication
requirement object and then you're
passing it in in the authorized async
method here's the user here's the
requirement and again it will tell you
is this allowed or is it not allowed no
so I guess when I run it again Here I am
I am a patient so I can't I can't do
anything here let's go back and be a
nurse okay so prescribe 10 milligrams
aspirin that works 20 shouldn't work
okay a ton of placebo yes works okay so
that's how you can encapsulate more
complicated authorization rules into
these requirement handlers and then you
give you our developers pretty you know
simple to use API authorized acing user
requirement and then you know magic
happens okay so that's the other thing
yeah we've seen that the last thing I
want to mention here with regards to a
spirit core is thereby also global a
spinet cauterization policy so the same
policy system that you've just seen that
you can put into di you can also
hardwire to MVC it's an MVC feature
really yeah
so basically inside when you spend when
you call add and we see you have this
options action and then you can create a
policy and this policy can be
arbitrarily complex but it can be easy
like only authenticate users it can be a
little bit more not so easy or I can
again include custom requirements which
makes custom code run and so on so you
can make it as sophisticated as you want
I guess and then you're just putting
that policy on an authorization filter
and attach that to the filters pipeline
and then it will run for every incoming
requests into the application and that's
you know also quite useful to have okay
so
coming back to my slide yeah that's my
summary again you might come to
different conclusions that that's just
how we think it works for us and we have
implemented it a couple of times
successfully in in different projects
but you know if it's all about global
application access use the global policy
yeah use access tokens if it's about
feature access I think roles permissions
work really well once you are inside the
feature yeah I don't think it's
authorization anymore I think it's
business logic and to be honest that the
medication example I gave you with the
amount and the type of medication that
is already pretty crossing the line I
think to to business logic right because
you probably if you're building
hospitals of you probably have as a core
business feature an understanding of how
much a patient can take from which
whatever so it's you know it's already
already might violate this right which
what I'm saying is it's pretty easy to
get that wrong ma'am how much time do we
have ten more minutes so whatever I can
quickly show you is this their UI week
we created for that which is not part of
the open source version but you know you
need you guys to make managers happy no
okay so same idea just that you now can
graphically manage these things so this
would be our same example as we've seen
and in the code right it's the emergency
room application where we have talked us
nurses and patients and you can see that
you see that you can assign users to
application roles either aesthetically
by user IDs or by virtue of mapping
incoming roles into it or here's an
example of often of a c-sharp expression
so if the if the person is very sick he
must be a patient okay and then you can
go to the permissions and assign that
here another example would be a more
complicated one again
this was inspired by my customer that
builds hospital software so they start
with a single application right and
build their own
authorization system build their own
authentication system and nowaday they
created the second one and the third one
and now they needed to share users
between those and give them single
sign-on so that's where identity came in
but now they realized even the the same
doctor has access to free systems but
has different permissions also they
built three times a permission system
for each application so the way we can
solve that for example is with you know
with child policies okay so we have a
top-level policy called hospital system
right and you can have your user
mappings on top like whose admin whose
back office employees problem but you
see no permissions here now this is just
the container and then we have sub
policies which are the actual
applications here so in medical records
you know you have things like create
delete update in accounting you have pay
invoice whatever and now you can use the
roles and use us you had at the top
level to map them to permissions in
choice level for example um and I
mentioned earlier that some people like
the resource-based view of the world so
that's something you can do as well so
in this case I'll let's say github yeah
would use our software they probably
will never do that but anyways so github
defines a couple of you know roles and
permissions like you know owner and
contributor and you know you create repo
and merge PR and these things right and
then when Dominic creates an account
with github you could create a child
policy called Dominic yeah and then when
Toni creates a repo that could have a
child policy called repo one and now
Dominic could you know in the UI allow I
don't know Philip to merge appear okay
and that's more like a resource based
thing where you attach permissions to a
resource tree in your system and you can
do inheritance on that as well yeah so
that's our current thinking as I said
it's a it's a bit of a brain dump of of
the things we we did for the last year
it works so far I must say it works
really well
as I said the all the code you've seen
is on github so if you like that pattern
yeah just take it change it to whatever
you want here you can also see the the
documentation for the A's peanut co-op
policy system which is quite good and
the first one was a blog post I wrote
two years ago that kick-started the
whole the whole thing that's all I have
thank you very much and because I always
forget there are stickers thank you